hey David do you believe that the number
of seats in the House of Representatives
should be expanded this came up on a
recent YouTube livestream that I did and
my answer is basically yes I do right
now each House seat represents about
750,000 people and there have been 435
seats in the House of Representatives
dating all the way back to the late 20s
I believe 1929 and obviously the
population of the United States has
grown hugely I think it's almost three
times bigger today than it was back in
1929 maybe even more I'm now just going
by rough numbers but the point is each
congressional district used to include
way fewer people than it does today and
if we wanted to keep the same
proportional representation that we had
in 1929 today we should grow the House
of Representatives to somewhere between
eleven hundred and twelve hundred
members okay we have 435 and what you
have to understand when you think about
this issue is that this runs directly
counter to the interests of those who
are already in the House of
Representatives what I mean by that is
if you got elected to the House of
Representatives and you currently
represent 750,000 people and you are one
out of 435 why would you want to see
your power diminished by expanding the
number of seats in the House of
Representatives because what you would
effectively be doing is you would reduce
the number of people that you represent
by reducing the number of people in each
congressional district and you would be
voting to make yourself not one out of
one hundred and one out of 435 you make
yourself one out of a thousand or one
out of 1200 and most of the elected
officials aren't going to want to reduce
their own power it's just not something
most people want to do it's similar to
campaign finance reform and I've talked
about this before when we ask our
elected officials to change the campaign
finance system yes some of them say I
want to do it and I would vote for it
and I'll do it and I guess we believe
them when they say that but if you were
elected to begin with with a particular
campaign
and system many of those people are not
going to want to take apart the system
that got them elected to begin with now
there are people who are thinking this
through a little bit more critically and
they realize that if we change the
entire system everybody benefits and
maybe their party actually benefits more
I would argue that Democrats would
benefit more from reforms to the
campaign finance system than Republicans
and that's when you can actually get
some sort of partisan agreement right
the reason that you would see
significant support for expanding the
number of seats in the House of
Representatives would be if one party
determines that it would be good for
them I believe that it would be better
for Democrats Democrats would benefit
more when you expand the number of seats
you shrink the advantage of the
electoral college for Republicans
currently that favors Republicans and
there are other sort of more micro ways
that I believe it would benefit
Democrats but to make a long story short
yes we absolutely should expand the
number of seats in the House of
Representatives good luck doing it
significant opposition would be seen
definitely from Republicans maybe even
from centrist Democrats as well so I
don't know that I see it happening
anytime soon
although I would love it if you disagree
with me let me know I want to know why
why should we not expand the number of
seats in the House of Representatives it
used to expand with population and it is
not since 1929 what's so special and
perfect about 435 we've got a great
bonus show for you today become a member
or a patron to get instant access to the
bonus show